good day and welcome to nature's returns
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for business and the
environment my name is Andrew woo and I
will be your host for today's webinar
titled tackling the challenge of
creating water quality markets the Yale
Center for business and the environment
is pleased to continue nature's returns
a webinar series that addresses the
growing importance of ecosystem service
valuation and investment each
presentation is recorded and available
on the Yale iTunes U channel we are also
excited to share news of a new
partnership between the Center for
Business and the environment at Yale
with the conservation finance network
this initiative will provide original
content and share timely news events and
resources on conservation finance online
founded at Island Press in 2012 the
conservation finance network seeks to
accelerate the pace and scale of land
and resource conservation restoration
and stewardship in the United States to
the application of financial tools and
strategies by delivering intensive
trainings and building a network of
professionals from across the
conservation finance and philanthropic
sectors CFN helps to increase the
financial resources deployed for
conservation we are pleased to have Todd
Gardner and Bobby Cochran with us today
Todd gartner is a senior associate for
the World Resources Institute food
forests and water program he runs w is
natural infrastructure for water project
working with governments and businesses
to invest in ecosystem conservation and
restoration in order to secure fresh
water supplies reduce flood risks and a
plain other economic and social benefits
Bobby Cochran is the executive director
for the Willamette partnership a
non-profit coalition of business
environmental and other leaders working
to enhance the pace and slowly and
effectiveness of restoration in the West
today Todd and Bobby will engage in an
interactive conversation on the national
network on water quality trading and its
new report bill
building a water quality trading program
options and considerations sharing the
vision of developing a national network
to improve riparian zones Gardner and
Cochran will explore strategies to
construct consistent models of water
quality markets before we begin the
presentation we would like to remind our
listeners that questions are welcomed
and will be directed to our speaker at
the conclusion of the talk you can type
questions directly into the gotomeeting
chat window and with that we welcome
Todd and Bobby nature's returns thank
you Andrew for the warm introduction
huge thanks to everyone for taking time
out of their busy day for joining us for
this conversation on the national
network for water quality trading and I
understand there are a bunch of folks in
crude hall on the Yale campus right now
enjoying some of the amazing new haven
pizza during this webinar and both Bobby
and I are quite jealous as we're sitting
on our morning coffee out here in Oregon
but we are honored to have the
opportunity to engage with you and
describe the work that has happened over
the last two-plus years on the national
network on water quality trading an
initiative that w RI and the Willamette
partnership have co-ordinated before we
jump into the content just wanted to
take a quick second to allow bobbi and
myself to more formally introduce the
Willamette partnership and the World
Resources Institute so Bobby maybe I'll
pass it to you real quickly just so you
can further introduce your amazing
organization well Todd we always talk
with your trying to keep expectations
low so we can exceed them but thanks for
that I appreciate it and Andrew thanks
for having us yes LM partnership we're a
non-profit out here in in Oregon but
we're doing a lot of work on
market-based work across the western us
both on the habitats and water side and
really trying to figure out how we can
quantify the good stuff that land
managers are doing and in ways that
other people can
best in and trying to move money from
dumb stuff the better stuff and then
working on the policies that make that
just an easier choice whether that's
figuring out how you can get health care
and Medicaid to pay for green
infrastructure whether it's working with
wastewater utilities to invest in
repairing and restoration just that's
all pretty similar and in services the
same mission and so being part of the
national network on water quality
trading was a real pleasure for us so
that's that's who we are Todd great
thanks Bob Ian and the world resources
institute WRI is an environmental think
tank based in Washington DC but I'm
fortunate enough to get to hang out with
Bobby and his friends out in Portland
Oregon WRI has been around for about 30
years and most of our work is
international with the focus on
developing countries we spend six
different resource areas climate energy
cities and sustainable transportation
food security forests and water and if
Andrew mentioned my work really spans
the forest and the water resource areas
at WRI and water quality trading has
been a core focus over the last ten plus
years for the Institute and a lot of
that work has focused in the Chesapeake
Bay region thinking through how we truly
get water quality training to scale what
an inter trade interstate trading
platform might look like and then more
recently moving out to the mississippi
area and then thinking through how we
take all of those lessons learned and
experiences and bring them to a national
forum which is why we are on the call
today so just make sure that everyone is
on the same page when we talk about
water quality trading we think of it as
an innovative market-based approach that
allows stakeholders to achieve water
quality global goals more efficiently
and most cases more cost-effectively as
well it's based on the concept that
different players in a watershed face
different costs to control the same
pollutants so whether you're trying to
reduce sediments nutrients temperatures
there's different opera
communities and different costs
associated with different interventions
and reduction approaches so a wastewater
treatment plant for example oftentimes
faces a much higher pollution control
costs to meet the regulatory obligation
than a farmer working on his field so
water quality trading is a system based
on roba science very clear rules and
procedures a robust monitoring and
verification process that truly allows
waste water and other point sources to
buy nutrient reduction credits from
agricultural producers and other what we
call nonpoint source entities who are
often able to reduce those pollutants at
a much lower cost and with the growing
nutrient pollution crisis if you will
across the u.s. we're going to need more
innovative approaches and ones that are
much more holistic and so we think that
water quality trading if done right
really fits that bill flexibility in
meeting regulations more cost-effective
and a lot of CO benefits that are
recognized one of the one of the
examples that we often talk about is one
in the areas where Bobby and I call home
in Oregon Clean Water Services which is
wastewater utility which feeds the
metropolitan area of portland had an
issue to deal with right so they had a
regulatory requirement to dramatically
reduce the thermal loading going into
the tualatin nerve and they had a couple
of different options in front of him one
was to literally build a refrigerator on
the end of their tailpipe so a cooling
tower that would have cost them between
60 and 150 million dollars and it was
pretty certain it would have met the
regulatory requirement but it wasn't
going to meet all of the other watershed
management objectives that clean water
services and other stakeholders hope to
achieve plus it was really expensive so
they were looking at alternative
opportunities and quickly understood
that a water quality trading program
which
would focus on planting riparian forests
along the length of about 35 miles of
stream could provide the same thermal
load reduction so really shading the
river preventing it from heating up
providing the same environmental
benefits as the chiller at a
dramatically reduced cost not to mention
all of the incredible co-benefits that
would be recognized for salmon for other
wildlife species climate mitigation and
complementary income streams for
landowners in the basin so a much better
approach and the reason that so many
people often default to the gray is
because the rules that were set up in
the early 70s under the Clean Water Act
and other environmental regulations were
developed to address a very different
suite of problems most of the nutrient
issues were very much related to point
sources we're now operating in very
different context where non-point
sources in many or even most watersheds
is a much larger percentage of the
problem so water quality trading truly
allows us to address the root of these
concerns next slide please and this is
not just a theoretical idea if you look
at what Clean Water Services and when a
partnership and other partners in order
again put together they were able to
take what you see is a baseline in 2004
and over the next number of years
through a robust tree planting and
riparian enhancement process really
restore that area so you can see the
difference in just three short years and
then if you fast forward to 2010 you see
a well-functioning hydrological system
for considerably less expensive than the
gray infrastructure solution a huge win
for all involved and it serves as the
template which many are trying to
replicate next slide please and when I
talk about replication it's been a
really exciting time in the markets and
ecosystem services space in just water
quality trading alone there's a dozen or
so different states that have active
trading programs rules policies guidance
that recommend and suggest how a water
quality trading pro
should be developed operated maintained
verified and like over the last decade
we've seen a ton of experimentation USDA
deserves a lot of credit through their
conservation innovation grant program in
providing seed funding for these types
of programs allowing folks to experiment
with different approaches different
verification processes different ways to
calibrate and model out water quality
benefits and we've learned a great deal
we've made mistakes along the way but we
now understand many of the basic
premises that would serve as the
foundation for a robust credible and
transparent water quality trading
process we're now at a place in time
where we need to move from
experimentation into more onto a
paradigm more based on consistency and
build upon those lessons learned next
slide please Bobby so with that idea and
recognizing that there were some folks
in a variety of sectors truly
questioning how we get to a more
streamlined and consistent approach
around the idea of water quality trading
the Lana partnership and the world
resource and just Institute started
convening what we call the national
network old water quality trading and it
was designed to improve the consistency
integrity environmental performance of
water quality training and we did this
by pulling together all of the different
sectors that we deemed relevant for a
water quality training program to be
robust and sustainable and there's five
different actor groups that we wanted to
bring to the table and make sure that we
had their perspectives so we have the
agricultural community who represents
the nonpoint source constituency bands
we had folks that represented the
utility sector at electric power utility
entities on the point source side we had
folks from the state regulatory
divisions to DEQ s and the DEP s who
after the ones that are approving
programs and helping issue guidance we
invited folks who are on the
practitioner side the ones that are
actually developing and designing these
programs and then ultimately wanted to
make sure that some of the folks that
had been critical in the past and that
were really focused on everything from
social justice issues to making sure
these programs truly built on the best
available science we're at the table as
well so we made sure that folks from the
environmental advocacy division were at
the table along with us and what we did
was we began by looking at all of the
different programs that were active or
had made attempts at water quality
trading programs over the last dozen or
so years and really tried to understand
what worked what didn't what were the
key foundational elements and what
ultimately might we want to suggest to
others who are starting their programs
today based on those lessons learned so
with that I'm going to pass it over to
Bobby to dig in a little bit deeper into
what we were able to come up with
through the national network process
great thanks a lot Todd yeah as we came
together for the national network it was
in a really interesting context I think
around the country there's over 25
different kind of point nonpoint water
quality trading programs that have
actively gotten through gotten approvals
to move into trading but more than 75
different places have tried to start and
a lot of times the startup can be costly
and time-consuming and it's tricky and
so I think when we were talking with a
lot of the organizations that you see
here on on this slide we were trying to
find a way could there be a set of
national standards around water quality
trading and very quickly this group said
water quality trading needs to be
responsive to local conditions there's
needs to be flexibility there needs to
be opportunity to promote innovation
so then we asked well could we set up a
series of best practices and even even
then I think folks really felt that that
doesn't provide the opportunity to think
about nutrients differently in Texas and
Louisiana than in Ohio and Iowa and so
what we ended up with with the options
and considerations document is a series
of the 11 key elements that are needed
to build a water quality trading program
and for every one of those elements
there's options that you could choose
options ABC and D on how you define the
trading area of where a credit can be
traded and if you choose options a
agriculture may hate you forever if you
choose option e environmental groups may
see you if you choose options b c and d
here are the pros and cons of when it
might make sense for those different
options and so we didn't say option a is
always the best but we were able to say
fairly straightforwardly what are the
pros and cons of each of those options
and where the examples of who's doing it
and not just that Wisconsin is doing
option C but here is the web link to the
document that describes Wisconsin's
approach and that's on you know page 17
not just generally Wisconsin is doing
this so it's a really in-depth resource
that's meant to kind of help new
programs and adaptively managed programs
get up get started and adapt much more
easily and readily so that the pieces
that are inherently local like the
science needed to quantify a credit
which best management practices on farms
are going to be most effective local
markets can really focus on those types
of inherently local questions and some
of the broader questions and experiences
that can apply just as easily in
California as it can in Texas ideally we
can skip through that stuff as fast as
possible so that's what the options and
considerations document does it wouldn't
have happened without some funding
support from USDA's office of
environmental markets and Natural
Resource Conservation Service
and the electric power research
institute so thank you to those folks
but then also the organization's you see
here also invested a lot of time and in
review every word and that 200 page
document was extensively negotiated over
the last two years so it's a 200 page
document we think it's very very well
written but it's beefy there's no doubt
that it's beefy and I'm going to open up
the pages and walk you through here some
of the key elements in a second but
we're also working very closely to
develop user tools that make it easier
to access that document and translate it
into more water quality trading programs
better water quality trading programs so
for each of those five sectors that Todd
described we have a briefing note so we
asked American Farmland trust to tell us
what are the what are the five issues
that agriculture is going to care most
about and point people to the parts of
the document that talk about those five
issues the National Association of clean
water agencies that represents kind of
wastewater utilities did the same for
their crew the association of clean
water administrators which are all the
state water quality agencies did it for
their sector troutman sanders and the
water quality trading alliance did it
for practitioners and then the
Environmental Law and Policy Center
wrote a briefing note for the
environmental community so all five of
those are put together we've also put
powerpoint templates that you're
actually seeing parts of today so if
anybody online is interested in more
follow-up or has a particular audiences
they think would benefit from more
information on the national network feel
free to give totter I a call or email
and we're happy to follow up and then
the other things we're working to build
is how do we build some of the templates
and tools and other things that take the
200 pages and make it easy for a state
agency or a set of stakeholders to adapt
so that's kind of where we're going now
in terms of the options and
considerations document itself
I covered a lot of this but the original
focus is on point to nonpoint trading we
didn't choose to focus on trades between
two wastewater facilities so the point
point trades at this point we don't
think there's that much difference we
also didn't focus explicitly on
stormwater offsets and trading although
there's a lot of overlap and a lot of
relevance and that's maybe one of the
things that the national network chooses
to take on next and I think that's one
thing from folks online is we'd love to
hear from you all on things you think
the national network should try and take
on next but a big part of what we also
did was try and develop consistent
definitions and languages for example
the word verification meant really
different things to folks in
Pennsylvania and Maryland or Oregon or
Wisconsin and so we tried to kind of
define terminology throughout one of the
things that's in the document is a set
of vision and kind of shared guiding
principles this was one of the things
that the national network group kind of
did come to consensus on us saying here
are the guiding principles that you know
you're accomplishing your regulatory and
environmental goals based in sound
science and it's accountable and
transparent a lot of these guiding
principles are not unique to water
quality trading and water quality
trading the the network was very clear
that it's not a silver bullet it's not
going to work in a lot of situations but
when you were able to figure out trading
as a tool to achieve clean water goals a
lot of those same kinds of discussions
or what you need for implementing other
parts of the Clean Water Act or
implementing broader watershed
investment priorities the other pieces
that was really important to
environmental groups was that it doesn't
produce local water quality impacts that
it's consistent with the Clean Water Act
regulatory framework and that there's an
appropriate compliance and enforcement
provisions those are the guiding
principles the 11 elements which each of
these elements has a chapter within
within the document starts off with okay
what's the policy and regulatory
instruments needed to support with
trading
I mentioned you know how many programs
have not actually delivered a trade and
a big part of that is the Clean Water
Act is just kind of funky it's it's not
easy to kind of work through some of the
structures of the Clean Water Act and in
trading kind of pushes the bounds of
kind of where total maximum daily load
do or do not apply how permit variances
mic work how compliance schedules work
there's a lot of nuance in the in the
Clean Water Act it's really important to
understand for trading to work so
chapter that's why we start with chapter
one on those issues chapter two is
really the kind of trading basics of who
where what and how so what do you have
to do prior to generating our credit who
can trade with whom uh if you generate a
pound of nitrogen reduction in Ohio can
you use that to offset a pound of
nitrogen discharge in Mississippi maybe
we talked about how you how you get to
the answers to that question we talked
about eligibility one of the most
controversial issues here is baseline
which is what farmers or other kind of
credit sellers need to get to in terms
of pollution reduction prior to
generating a credit we have a section on
the science needed to quantify water
quality benefits managing risk and
uncertainty and what is in this chapter
six is another important one is like
what is a credit and if you're in a
conservation finance world and you don't
your are crystal clear on what you're
financing it's pretty hard to do so
chapter six talks about how long is the
credit good for when does it come into
existence when does it go away and we
even flag some issues around kind of the
accounting treatment of credits or kind
of the idea of stacking multiple credits
but on some of those issues and network
didn't feel that the experience was ripe
enough to make affirmative options and
considerations around some of those
issues and some of those we flag
the issue and punted the other chapters
talk about you know how do you know a
credit is real and then how do you kind
of do the tracking and accounting over
time and the last chapter talks about
which types of organizations whether its
private sector or government agencies or
point sources themselves or farmers what
are the roles and responsibilities and
transaction models available in water
quality trading so those are the those
are the 11 elements and we actually
think those 11 elements is some of our
work on habitat or other types of
markets there's this a significant
amount of overlap so I think you know
the document itself is informative for a
lot of reasons let me take you down kind
of another another level of depth into
the document and you know so one of the
sections talks about what is a water
quality credit and we said you know it's
a measured or estimated unit of
pollutant reduction per unit of time at
a specified location that's what it is
we're buying and selling so the
conversation that we had that took you
know almost three to six months back and
forth on each one of these words is to
really get specific about what a credit
is and then there's a pollution
reduction that happens at the edge of a
farm field but that's not a credit until
you adjust it by baseline requirements
and somehow connect that pound of
phosphorus reduction in one part of Iowa
to the downstream wastewater discharge
so there's adjustments that get from the
edge of field down to the farm and
throughout the document wherever we
could we tried to put diagrams and to
clarify that that if you installed a
buffer at the edge of a field you might
reduce sixty percent of the phosphorous
that's leaving that field but only a
certain amount of that might actually
get into the stream and only a certain
amount of that might get from one part
of a stream down to another part of the
stream and that's called attenuation so
we we describe those different steps we
also kind of talked about okay a hundred
pounds per year reduced at the edge of
the field by that buffer strip
you have a baseline requirement for say
animal exclusion that takes your
available credit down to 90 pounds per
year you apply it a two-to-one trading
ratio to account for any kind of
uncertainty that means you've got 45
pounds per year of credits that you need
to sell and so we try to provide a
framework in a structure for how trading
programs can articulate what a water
quality credit is these that ideally
when a program is starting up in
Tennessee it doesn't need to spend a
year talking about what a water quality
credit is that hopefully we've given
enough structure to have a quick
conversation on that so that's that's
the national network document the
options and considerations document I'm
gonna jump back up a level and to talk
about what we're seeing more broadly as
challenges ahead for water quality
trading as a whole I think for for water
quality trading as a whole we can expect
to see increased legal activity around
trading I think there's and there's a
growing interest in trading you're
seeing 15 states that are already have
some form of trading policy in place
there's a number of others that are
actively considering trading policy
you've got a number of new permits that
are going to be incorporating trading
but you also have particularly from some
of our environmental friends some real
legitimate concerns about how those
trading permits and policies are
structured and so unless we can really
figure out how to address some of those
concerns we're going to see some legal
activity and we may even see some anyway
so that's just something to work through
I think certainly within the network we
saw this is there's this tension between
wanting flexibility within water quality
trading so you can customize what Iowa
needs which is going to be different
than what Tennessee needs first having
very specific requirements that provide
you know if you're trying to invest in
developing credits in Iowa or Tennessee
and you're the same conservation finance
person or the same aggregator of credits
you're going to want to know the
specific requirements see
some consistency across where you might
be working so that creates attention I
think we're not taking full advantage of
information technology with a lot of the
precision agriculture that's coming out
a lot of the fine resolution remote
sensing there's a lot we could do on
kind of monitoring of water quality
improvements both on verification credit
quantification that could drastically
reduce
particularly increase the effectiveness
of water quality improvements if we
could incorporate that more fully
there's a lot of debates over what
entity should do particularly we hear
this around well waste water facility
should zero out their pollution that
sounds good but you know you and I all
all live in a city and our waste one
ability helps take care of us similarly
all farmers should reduce all of their
pollution well that's a fine that's a
fine goal but there's some realities to
that and so that debate over what should
do versus what's possible is tough and
then I think a lot of this we get hooked
around the idea of tit-for-tat
equivalents of I'm going to put this
phosphorus in here and take it out over
here it gets a lot easier when we have a
really clear set of watershed goals with
some accountability on how we're
actually going to achieve a forty
percent reduction in phosphorus loading
in the next 40 years so those are some
of the challenges I think in terms of
promising trends we're seeing more state
and multi state programs so I think
you're going to you're going to see the
pace of trading and the scale of trading
increase we're seeing a much stronger
national communication innovation
transfer than what I saw happening ten
years ago so that's really encouraging
that an innovation that is developed in
Washington DC or in Virginia is fairly
quickly being transferred to other parts
of the country we're seeing a push for
consistent state policy and clear
standards and I think this is something
where the conservation finance community
has a really important role to play
we're seeing new technology so pretty
soon we're going to have water quality
monitoring devices that we can actually
track the phosphorus concentrations in a
part of a stream for say less than five
thousand dollars which will be huge and
I think the other trend you see is
trying to solve more than one problem at
a time that if we are looking at
restoring floodplains to protect down
communities and property for the
National Flood Insurance Program well a
lot of those same activities are going
to be what we need to deal with storm
water runoff we're going to be the same
things we need to deal with phosphorous
retention so if we can figure out how we
work with communities to solve more than
one problem at a time the idea of this
high cost of infrastructure hopefully
get some more integrated lens on it so I
think for Todd and I we're talking about
a particular ass for the conservation
finance community coming out of the
national network we're pretty darn
convinced that no one should have to
start from scratch that everybody should
be taking a look at this options and
considerations document and really
thinking hard about focusing your
resources on the stuff that's inherently
local and trying to stay as consistent
as possible with what everybody else is
doing around the country and then also
really being clear to people that you
need to define what you're selling
before you can finance it a lot of the
local folks that we work with jump right
to transaction models what does kinds of
transaction models that we can use to
spy and sell credits and we're trying to
really hit home that unless you know
what I credit is it doesn't really
matter what your transaction model is
and then I think the other challenge
with water quality is you're going to be
dealing with lots of smaller
disaggregated projects overall and so
what is the financing structure look
like for those small projects aggregated
together and then I think the the last
piece is I think there's a lot of
interest in continuing the work of the
national network I think the original
participants are really interested in
broadening that tent too much bigger
group of people that there was a value
and having that diverse dialogue that
created is deliverable to help move the
world farther along but we need to know
what you need so tell us what are the
key issues that a diverse group of
people where you have milk producers and
Environmental Defense sitting right next
to each other what could they hash out
that would be useful to you so we'd be
particularly interested in the next
couple months hearing from you all on on
that
and I think with with that Todd we
should probably turn to some of the
questions and see what people want to
talk about but the documents are all
available on world Reese the optional
consideration document is available on
World Resources Institute site it's also
available on the partnership site and
the partnership site also has those five
sector summaries that I talked about and
a number of the other tools that are
available and so you can download those
documents if you really like a hardbound
paper copy you can also let us know and
we can find a way to get you a hardbound
copy so Todd just before we start
turning it over to questions is there
anything key that i missed or a point
you wanted to hammer home yeah I think
he did an incredible job working through
that so happy at paired over Q
discussion I'm not sounds great Bobby
and Todd thank you so much for
presentation we have some questions from
the audience and colleagues that we
would greatly appreciate your input on
Bobby you've talked about quantifying
water quality benefits as a key element
of water quality markets in our last
webinar with joe whitworth from this
freshwater trust Joe emphasized the need
to demonstrate quantitative evidence
that initiatives have made a significant
impact on wall equality and that you
know it's not just due to natural
variation you've touched on this briefly
when talking about not taking full
advantage of information technology but
can you elaborate on the current state
of monitoring technologies that measure
these results and their associated
economic costs ah that's a giant
question so I'm going to have asked the
question and then if folks want to
follow up again but I think in general
most of the water quality trading
programs are using two main forms of
quantification one is a series of kind
of BMP efficiency rates so if you
install a buffer there's a bunch of
research that's been done in the
Chesapeake Bay or in the Upper
Mississippi that says if you install a
buffer you're going to reduce about 60
of your phosphorus loading giving into a
river there's a number of programs that
use those BMP efficiency raise a lot of
other programs are also using dynamic
models where they're taking those BMP
efficiency rates and combining them with
climate and weather with soils with the
crop management practices that are that
are going on the ground almost no
programs are basing credits on direct
measurement of say phosphorus reduction
so there's not you know a monitoring
station at the end of a drain tile
that's saying okay for these five years
here is my baseline of phosphorus
concentration I installed this buffer
this cover crop and now I see a sixty
percent reduction and that's my credit I
think a lot of our environmental groups
that we talk to really want to get more
towards that direct measurement but you
know Jose Jose a point of we need to
demonstrate improvements beyond kind of
natural background variation that's
really true at a watershed scale it's
really hard at a project scale and so I
think that's where advances in
technology could take us to where direct
measurement at the project scale may be
increasingly possible but for right now
it's really challenging and part of that
is a cost question is direct measurement
the monitoring equipment is expensive
going out and regularly collecting that
data is expensive and I think also it's
really difficult to get the baseline of
kind of what the current car that you're
improving off
sounds great thank you now so Todd in
this national network process while
bringing together stakeholders with
diverse viewpoints like practitioners
agricultural producers and by mental
advocates can you elaborate on what
happens in key issues of contention
that's a great question i would i would
answer that in a couple of different
ways one of the beauties of the national
network and one of the things that
really became much clearer is we thought
that there was a lot more
contentiousness coming in then they're
actually ended up being once we had the
chance to sit down describe how all the
different programs had approached the
different issues have a chance to allow
people sort of a safe place space to
really work through some of the
differences of opinions and then really
start laying out the options and think
through the pros and the cons and the
potential ramifications if a program
elected to go one route for another so I
mean baseline I Bobby mentioned was
definitely one of the issues where there
was the most discussion I think
verification was another one how
frequently do you verify who has she
would have that role is eight agency a
third party non profit group how do you
think about the inherent transaction
costs that are associated with that one
of the things that was you know most
exciting for me is you know people maybe
were a little bit guarded at the very
beginning back in 2013 and by the time
we were on our fourth or fifth gathering
I think a lot of that had faded into the
background and people truly salt there
are a number of different approaches
that would work for any of the different
elements you just really need to be
thoughtful about you know who might be
in favor or against going for option a
versus option C so we were really
careful to to straddle that line between
options and recommendations and guidance
really trying to lay it out hey
you can do this but there is a body
mentioned a chance that you might get
sued by environmental advocacy group or
if you go this route a pretty good
chance that you're going to struggle to
recruit agricultural producers so I
would say you know baseline and
verification maybe were two of the
issues where there was the most heated
discussion but in the end I think we
ended up in a really good place by
simply laying out all of the options and
a lot of the pros and cons and where it
had been attempted before sweet so we
have a question from Chris and Jeffrey
so what sorts of financial products
involving water quality do you see being
developed in the near future how do you
see multiple smaller water quality
projects being grouped together into a
larger investment product and are there
any examples where this is being done
effectively that you could profile um I
can talk about a couple of things but
time going to want you to jump in here
to search you know the there's a couple
of different models that are out there
and it's less of putting it together
into a financial product it's so I'm
going to talk more about the transaction
models and then Todd let's noodle
through on what that means of putting it
into a financial product itself but
there's a lot of folks out there that
are doing some form of aggregation where
you have a third party either that's
someone like a freshwater trust that's
worked with a city of Medford freshwater
trust will have a contract with Medford
to deliver so many credits freshwater
trust will then go work with a number of
different land owners to aggregate
implement those projects aggregate the
credits up and then deliver those to
Medford as a package and that's a the
contract that they will do and they were
able to go and get the financing based
on on that contract and then you have
folks like pen vest in Pennsylvania
that's more of an exchange
change model where the pen vests will
actually create the space where buyers
and sellers can come come together and
they have bill host of auctions around
that the Great Miami program in Ohio is
also kind of a central or of a central
aggregator where multiple point sources
will say hey I'd like some credits to
give the money to Great Miami and Great
Miami then goes and runs an auction with
a number of different land owners to do
that so I wouldn't say those are
financial products per se the product is
tends to be just a contract but there's
different transaction models how do you
have anything to add to that yeah I
think you're right i think the
transaction models are relatively
straightforward you comfortably have
given a lot of thought to is you know
how do you aggregate landowners within a
watershed and then how do you start
thinking about aggregating programs
within a broader catchment so for
example there's been a ton of discussion
over the last few years about interstate
trading in the chesapeake bay region
those conversations are starting to to
happen now in some of the Gulf state
regions you know can you trade credits
that are generated on a farm in Maryland
to a point source in Pennsylvania or
Virginia if it's all feeding to the
Chesapeake Bay and there's a lot of
challenges with that different legal
thresholds different quantification
rules different trading ratios so in no
means have we have we gotten there but
that's one of the ways people are
thinking about sort of trying to get to
the scale that might be necessary to
attract additional capital beyond just
waste water utilities and other foreign
sources there's also a lot of discussion
again it's at the very early days one of
the beauties of water quality trading is
it's more holistic approach and taking
the ecosystem based approaches way more
beneficial than simply building a new
chiller or upgrading the treatment plant
is there a way to think about sort of
more of a one water solution where you
don't just think about wastewater you
try to think about impacts in the
stormwater context and on the drinking
water source water side is there a more
holistic ecosystem based approach that
might allow for additional financing and
capital to really meet our broader
ecosystem needs again that's really
early on in kind of the brainstorming
phase but hopefully those conversations
will continue to evolve and Todd would
it be fair to say that part of the
challenge is with the interstate trading
in Chesapeake or some of these other the
one water solution is that we just
haven't gotten clear and enough places
on exactly what a credit is with enough
certainty in terms of the policies and
other things that that credit is
acceptable to people that absolutely yes
or yes our limiting factor is not really
creative financial products I have all
the faith in the world of the finance
sector to come up with the right
financial product and so i'm i'm
spending almost all of my energy right
now trying to get clarity on what the
policies and the structures are that
define what the credit is and then
people can choose whatever transaction
model or financial product they'd like
from that one's work we're clear on on
what the piece of barley is or the the
corn is or in this case the
environmental benefit is todd i'm
probably i'm really glad that you guys
talked about this issue um holistic
thinking we have a question from Steve
that builds on this previous question
aside from aggregating projects there's
also the question of aggregating
different types of credits have there
been instances or case studies of
stacking credits like wetland mitigation
credits with water quality credits yes
so that is a question that we knew was
coming and it's one of Bobby and my
least favorite question to answer and
there's a number of reasons for that I
mean it's an important issue to consider
thus far it really hasn't been
big issue in reality so they're
generally have not been many cases where
you see folks trying to buy carbon
credits off of land where water quality
credits are being generated or habitat
mitigation offset credits where you're
seeing wetland mitigation credits
established in many ways you know we
decided not to directly address that in
this document and I think in many cases
it really is in some cases like US Fish
and Wildlife actually has some draft
guidance around the issue of when
habitat offset can be bundled or stacked
with other type of credits but in many
cases it comes down to the lake local
stakeholder consortiums and what they
feel most comfortable with some people
make the very clear and articulate
argument that it really is going to take
an aggregated set of income streams to
get enough landowners participating for
this stuff to really have the landscape
scale impact that we're hoping to
achieve and I totally get that and they
use the analogy of you know a cow for
example that you might sell the milk and
then the meat and then the skin and and
what have you and there's very different
income streams for the same you know
quote-unquote entity your product and
why is it any different for an ecosystem
selling the carbon and the water and
habitat other people make the claim very
clearly that we are short changing
ourselves in the amount of environmental
uplift that we're able to achieve if we
allow that Fame acre of land to be sold
multiple times so it would already be
restored via the water quality trading
revenue why would we allow a carbon
mitigation credit to also be recognized
on that same land there isn't true
additionality because it would have
happened even without the additional
carbon revenue so both both both angles
I think have merit and I think it'll
sort of play itself out over time as all
of these markets continue to mature
I'm not sure if you have anything
additional you want to add there yeah
and I'm speaking now as well I'm a
partnership no no association here with
the national networks positions on
things at all to me credit stacking is a
very distracting issue at this stage of
development of this stuff the only time
I hear it being advocated for is coming
from the supply side and a supply side
is not the limiting factor there's much
better ways to get it holistic
investment stacking just raises the
specter of you know this is a shell game
with a lot of the folks that we work
with that said we worked with department
of state land and clean water services
in oregon to develop the half mile and
mitigation Bank that has water quality
credit salmon credits and wetland
credits and there's not stacking going
on there that basically those credits
are linked and so when you sell fifty
percent of your wetland credits your
ledger for your salmon and your water
quality credits gets decreased by fifty
percent I think some of the better ways
to go after more holistic strategies is
having a good water should plan setting
goals that are holistic choosing the
types of bmps that you want to
prioritize or incentivize that are going
to create multiple benefits there's a
very different part of being holistic in
terms of your overall goals providing
information on the benefits of credit or
an action is providing that's different
than kind of the asset or the credit
that you're transacting and i would say
leave the credit asset stacking stuff
aside for right now there's other bigger
better things to work on also the
electric power research institute did
just get a grant from usda to look at a
stacking of carbon and water quality
credits off some of their ohio so they
don't know if it's going to work but
they're going to give it a good run a
really robust run at trying to figure
out what that could look like sounds
good and we'll see how it turns out we
now have a question from geeky who says
as you know green banks are emerging
across the nation as a means of
financing environmental projects to your
knowledge are these green banks like the
New York green bank or the Connecticut
greenbank aggregating you're considering
water projects for financing as they are
with carbon reduction projects I'll give
that to you know I don't know what a new
york green banker kinetic Gregorian bank
is yeah I apologize that I'm not super
familiar with that matter that's totally
fine so we have a common question from
Lee asking can you comment on the
current dollar scale of active trading
programs and what your hopes or
predictions are for the future yeah for
the dollar scale the forest trends an
ecosystem marketplace just publish their
state of watershed payments so i would i
would refer you to to that document on
on their website that breaks down the
state of watershed payments and they'll
have a section on water quality trading
i don't remember what the numbers of
millions off the top of my head but it's
the multiple millions and i would say
though that the greatest rise in terms
of dollar volume is coming out of the
stormwater offsets programs particularly
in Virginia and North Carolina and
potentially coming out of Maryland here
soon so I think last year the figure out
of Virginia was like 10 million dollars
in one year so that's where in terms of
dollar volume I'd be looking really
closely at stormwater offsets
yes I would agree and I would say that
you know Philadelphia and DC with some
of their new stormwater regulations may
be sort of that that next batch of
municipalities where stormwater credits
are going to be quite valuable in the
overall transaction volume is going to
be quite robust in terms of you know
what we hope I would frame it like this
there was a report two years ago by
McKinsey Consulting company that
suggested they will be over ten trillion
dollars spend or water infrastructure by
a 23 if we're able to see five percent
of that directed towards natural systems
I think that would be a huge win for
water quality and watershed services and
all the other ecosystem values that we
care about sounds great so just to wrap
things up we have one major question for
both of you taking the guiding
principles that you've outlined in the
report what would you recommend be the
next steps for those that are interested
in developing these local water quality
trading markets
front of that oh you were gonna let me
go I'm going to eat it either way you
started off and I'll fill in the gaps
that sounds good I think so if a new
program is wanting to start up and I
would say a new program that's looking
at source water protection water quality
or habitat but primarily this is a water
quality trading kind of document yeah
you should you should read the options
in considerations document you know it's
it's it's not a sit-down read one
through kind of thing it's a reference
document but certainly take a look at
the executive summary pull some of the
sector summary so you see how the
environmental groups or the wastewater
guys kind of think about this and really
think hard about where you can be eighty
percent the same as everybody else and
so you can concentrate your twenty
percent on what you need to do and if
you have a question don't be shy about
calling Todd or I or any of the other
participants early participants of the
national network yeah I mean just just
following up on what Bobby said you know
the national network options
considerations document is an incredible
place to start you oftentimes running
that first paragraph of a paper is the
heart of thing in many ways that's
already been done for you to really look
at how you can use the templates and the
guidance and contextualize it for your
locale the other thing I would say is
don't do it in the back room of the
state agency or in the conference room
of your local nonprofit you think about
this as a true your multi stakeholder
effort that is likely the only way that
you're going to get the diversifying
that you're going to need not just for
that first trade but for a long-standing
sustainable endeavor it's much better to
understand the concern and the risks
from the agricultural community the
environmental sector up front and try to
work through them and and you know sink
through the pros and cons a different
approaches early on then to spend
five hundred thousand dollars in 18
months and then realized that the way
you've been approaching things may not
fly because of the real you know
concerns of one sector or another so
there is the content and there is the
regulatory processes and considerations
but like most environmental issues you
know that there's a real social
component as well and don't undersell
the time and effort it will take to
bring people together towards these
common goals and Todd that this reminded
me to that anytime you can kind of grab
a buddy I think we're we're seeing a lot
of benefit if you're wanting to start up
a trading program of grabbing a
neighboring state and doing it at the
same time or at least grabbing a couple
watersheds in within the same state and
doing it all at the same time because
you can take your lessons together and
get this stuff going faster and cheaper
and then I think the other ask would be
if you're if you're noodling on
something and having a hard time getting
through an issue don't be shy about
asking asking for help there's a there's
a lot of people now that are better
connected than they ever were that can
provide some of those those lessons
learned yes sounds great and that
concludes the talk on water quality
markets once again we would like to
thank Todd Gartner and Bobby Cochran for
joining us today if you wish to view a
recording of this webinar please visit
the Yale Center for business and the
environment website or access the
recording to the Yale iTunes University
podcast thank you for joining us until
next time this is andrew woo from the
yale center for business and the
environment in collaboration with the
conservation finance network